on est des confirmés au nom comment
allez vous tourner cette vidéo le jure
de déconfinement donc je suis un peu
heureux parce qu'il ya plein de gens qui
vont être heureux de nouveau et ça ça me
rend heureux
déjà chiant écouter aujourd'hui je vais
raconter une histoire
une fois de plus mais parra serait
d'horreur rien à boire depuis quelques
jours je suis plongé dans les histoires
de parc d'attractions avant de vous
raconter l'histoire la plus folle sur
laquelle je suis tombé je vais vous
raconter celle qui a attisé ma curiosité
sur ce sujet là et c'est celle du thread
de l chiquito vous allez comprendre
pourquoi j'ai été happé pourquoi j'ai
voulu en savoir plus et pourquoi je suis
tombé sur ce que je vais vous raconter
en second temps je suis très excitée
elle a en fait je trouve ça tellement
incroyable j'ai envie de partager ça
avec vous là qu'on puisse en discuter
bref le thread chiquito parle donc d'un
scandale autour d'un toboggan qui
s'appelle le verrückt water slide gpad
accent allemand je sais pas comment ça
se dit enfin c'est une attraction qui
fait partie du parc aquatique cheater
ban on ne souligne pas la prononciation
donc le chili thurman et lui ouvre ses
portes en 2009 à kansas city après un
investissement de 750 millions de
dollars
c'est un assez grand parent qui a trait
à traction une sorte de village vacances
ça fait à peu près 160 mille mètres
carrés bref ces genres un truc
monstrueux et pour vous donner quelques
chiffres que je ne savais pas du tout il
faut savoir que les parcs d'attractions
c'est un business de malades
rien qu'en 2009 ça a généré 22 milliards
de dollars et il ya eu plus de 270
millions de personnes qui sont allées
dans des parcs d'attractions c'est
énorme et petite stat rassurante pour
ceux qui ont peur des attractions et de
la fiabilité mécanique de ces dernières
comme moins chaque année surtout ses
visiteurs la y en a en moyenne 7000 qui
finissent aux urgences ça fait 0 0025 9%
c'est ridicule donc soyez rassurés bref
en novembre 2012 le parc annonce
l'ouverture prochaine d'une nouvelle
attraction extraordinaire qui battrait
le record du monde du toboggan aquatique
le plus haut et je crois aussi qu'ils
voulaient battre le record du monde de
la vitesse atteinte dans le toboggan
bref jack & jones et les deux gars qui
se lancent dans cette aventure de merde
pourquoi de merde parce qu'ils veulent
faire ça en seulement neuf mois et
ouvrir cette attraction dès juillet 2013
alors c'est un peu moins galère à
construire qu'à un grand huit comme
osiris où le train de la mine je sais
pas quoi mais développer des attractions
ça reste de l'ingénierie et nous là tout
ce qu'on joue à roller coaster tycoon on
sait à quel point c'est chaud il faut
pas se rater à des jours de danse
peuvent mourir
bref au moment ils se lancent ce pari
fou fait savoir que le record du monde
du toboggan le plus haut est détenu par
kilimandjaro une attraction dans un parc
au brésil et ce toboggan culmine à 49,9
m jeff et john ils ont donc neuf mois
pour design et construire un prototype
faire des tests construire à taille
réelle refaire des tests et ouvert la
traction est alors la question qu'on se
pose tous ses commandes jeunes et jeff
peste-t-il leur attraction très bonne
question est malheureusement ces ghettos
et place des embarcations en haut du
toboggan dans laquelle il met des sacs
de sable puis l'envoie dans le toboggan
et il prie pour que le truc arrive en
bas intacte
[Musique]
jeff reed jeunes ne sont pas du tout
ingénieur et ça se voit les mecs ne base
pas leur répartition des masses sur des
calculs physiques et base s'assure de la
chance en plaçant des sacs de sable un
peu aléatoirement dans l'embarcation en
fait ça me termine parce que n'importe
qui d'entre nous aussi devait des années
une attraction dans laquelle va y avoir
des milliers de gens on se chie ray
dessus au frais attention au moindre
détail à elle sortirait sept ans après
eux ils s'en bat les couilles
ils en ont vraiment rien à [ __ ] bref
la construction de la traction en taille
réelle est terminée ils font de nouveau
un test avec une embarcation remplie de
sacs de sable et qu'est ce qui se passe
c'est chaud l'embarcation
ça ne marchera pas a la chance il faut
calculer gueule devenir ingénieur dans
les trois mois qui restent avant
l'ouverture officielle du toboggan
c'est chaud du coup nos amis ont flambé
il met un filet tout le long du toboggan
comme ça si l'embarcation commence à
partir pas le fils et la bloque ça me
fascine de voir comme les humains
parfois son fort pour trouver des plans
b au juste ils contournent le problème
faire appel à des ingénieurs pour
calculer l'angle la vitesse et la
physique on mettre un filet qui recouvre
tout le toboggan jeffrey john faut quand
même appel à un consultant en sécurité
non pas pour savoir si l'idée du filet
est bonne ils sont certains qu'elle est
bonne mais pour avoir une idée de la
limitation d'âge qui devrait mettre en
place sur cette attraction est le
consultant sécurité leur dis les gars
faut au moins partir ceux du moins de
saison jeff et john sont quand même un
minimum responsable et décide le jour de
l'ouverture de la traction de retirer la
limite d'âge directement n'y a plus de
limite d'âge le niveau d'inconscience il
est total c'est terrible les joggeurs à
la paix dans le confinement ils vous ont
énervé jeff et john c'est autre chose
c'est un autre level l'attraction ouf
donc en juillet 2016 comme il avait la
prétention de battre hardcore et qu'ils
ont battus ils font appel à beaucoup de
presse pour couvrir le lancement pendant
les jours et les semaines qui suivent il
ya des canaux qui effectivement se
soulève
au moment du passage de la deuxième
bosse c'est celle là qui pose problème
c'est celle là il aurait fallu des mecs
qui calcule mais il se passe rien de
hyper grave et c'est un mois après
l'ouverture de la traction le 7 août
2016 que malheureusement se passe
un terrible accident il ya un jeune
enfant de 10 ans qui s'appelle caleb web
qui monte dans l'attraction avec deux
personnes qui sont à l'arrière sur la
seconde boss calais heurte de plus
fouet le filet de sécurité ce qui va lui
coûter la vie puisque ça lui a tout
simplement arraché la tête les deux
personnes derrière caleb se fond
complètement rap et le visage par le
filet et c'est les trois dernières
personnes à avoir descendu le verrückt
puisqu'il a définitivement fermée après
cet incident les médias couvrent la
faire tout le monde en parle parce que
c'est quand même super grave
un accident d'une telle gravité dans un
parc d'attractions le parc ferme ses
portes
aussitôt et ré ouvre trois jours plus
tard c'est tout l'attraction elle bien
évidemment reste à fermer à jamais et le
22 février 2019 toutes les charges
portées contre les deux propriétaires du
parc des faits john sont levés ils sont
totalement libres ils n'ont aucune
condamnation alors qu'ils ont clairement
tué un enfant alors pourquoi cette
injustice et pas parce qu'on n'est pas
en france on est au kansas et la balle
et loi vis-à-vis des parcs d'attractions
étaient très très laxiste à ce moment là
c'est à dire qu'ils avaient bien des
standards de sécurité mis en place par
la stm
l'organisme officiel qui se charge de ça
mais rien n'oblige et dans la loi les
parcs d'attraction à respecter ces
standards de sécurité
voilà comment en 2016 deux trous de
balles ont conçu une attraction qui a
coûté la vie à un enfant et des
blessures de malades à des tas d'autres
gens alors rassurez-vous comme je
voulais dit embraya très très très peu
d'accidents par rapport au nombre de
gens qui visitent des parcs
d'attractions surtout au moment où on se
parle mais dans les années 80 il ya un
parc d'attractions monga son histoire
elle est incroyable et c'est de ça dont
on va parler maintenant c'est l'histoire
de a ction parc
[Musique]
à
ann john parkes alors à la base c'était
pas pareil d'attraction c'était une
station de ski qui s'appelait lavernhe
new jersey va les skis et resorts et
rolo en 1976 les propriétaires de cette
station de ski veulent attirer des gens
hors saison c'est à dire quand il n'y a
pas de neige et qui fait chaud ils
décident alors de construire deux
énormes rampe de luge d'été
vous avez sûrement déjà fait bref là on
est en 76 c'est le tout début de ce
délire de luge d'été et les
propriétaires du parc décide de vendre
ça comme un truc adapté à tout le monde
les enfants les ados et les jeunes
adultes les grands parents ils veulent
vraiment vendre l'aspect familial du
truc alors que chez mega dangereux mais
pas du tout fait pour les enfants
bref la publicité porte ses fruits il ya
pas mal de gens qui viennent voir un peu
ses luges d'été qui viennent hors saison
et du coup le propriétaire décide
carrément de faire un parc aquatique et
c'est là le début des emmerdes
il ajoute donc deux toboggans aquatiques
une piscine d'autres parcours de luge
d'été et même un terrain de tennis pour
qu'ils soient plus vendeur et décide
alors d'appeler ça le action parc
il faut se dire que pour l'époque c'est
l'un des premiers parcs de ce genre tu
pouvais faire du kart tu pouvais faire
des espèces de faune grand prix de
formule 1 dans des voitures bien moins
puissante que les formule 1 mais qui
bombardaient quand même tu pouvais
conduire des mini tank qui tiraient des
balles de tennis s'avère trop bien j'ai
envie moi de faire le mini torque alors
comment il était foutu ce parc va y
avait trois parties la première partie
s'appelait motors world c'est tellement
américain ça me tue pouvaient conduire
des bateaux à grande vitesse
il y avait aussi des bateaux autos
tamponneuses c'est comme les autos
tamponneuses mais sur l'eau là vous avez
envie d'aller action parc met d'accord
moi aussi j'ai envie d'y aller mais
attendez ces dernières attractions les
autos tamponneuses bateau avait une
petite particularité c'est que les
véhicules lâché plein d'essence dans
l'eau sauf que comme le but c'était de
se rentrer dedans ça faisait des remous
et du coup il ya beaucoup d'essence qui
gicle et sur les gens qui conduisait les
bateaux donc souvent quand je sortais de
l'attraction était recouverte d 106 est
très agréable passons maintenant à la
seconde partie du parc toutes les
attractions où il n'y a pas d'eau et de
moteurs des trucs un peu plus classique
que ya dans pas mal de fête foraine
encore actuellement genre la boule relié
à deux élastiques des sauts dans le vide
à l'élastique et surtout la luge d'été
on en a un peu parlé tout à l'heure mais
ses peluches d'été elle avait un vrai
gros problème la plupart des luges d'été
c'est une poignée et plus tu tires sur
la poignée plus à fresnes
là c'était pas réellement un frein
c'était juste comme un interrupteur et
avait deux modes y avait le mode lan qui
apparemment était vraiment très lents il
avait le mode rapide qui apparemment
était vraiment très rapide
du coup il y avait régulièrement des
gens qui étaient éjectés hors de la
rampe parce qu'il arrivait trop vite
dans un virage et il se fracasser dans
les roches qui
et aux alentours de la piste de luge un
mort c'est bon un mort suite à ça le
parc s'est dit waouh ya quelqu'un qui
vient de mourir dans une de nos
attractions on va peut-être la modifier
et la rendre un peu plus smooth pas du
tout ils n'ont rien changé
tout cela nous amène à la troisième
partie la plus tristement célèbres du
parc waterworld là c'est un bordel sans
nom je n'ai jamais vu autant de
toboggans et de trucs aquatique au même
endroit ça n'a aucun sens pour commencer
une énorme piscine à vagues qui peut
accueillir jusqu'à 1000 personnes en
même temps quelle bonne idée
c'est quelqu'un est en train de se noyer
on va le voir y perd facilement le cycle
de la piscine à vagues ces 20 minutes de
vagues et dix minutes de pause donc ça
carbure fort toute la journée quand
j'étais plus jeune j'étais allé dans une
piscine à vagues aquaboulevard et il y
avait ce genre que trois fois par jour
un moment où il y avait 15 minutes de
piscine à vagues parce que c'est
extrêmement dur de surveiller autant de
gens dans un endroit où il ya des vagues
et de voir une personne qui est
potentiellement en train de se noyer
les maîtres nageurs ont expliqué que les
jours où il y avait plus de monde au
parc ça leur arrivait de sauver jusqu'à
30 personnes de la noyade
c'est énorme un titre de comparaison en
moyenne un maître nageur lors d'une
saison entière il sauvé entre une et
deux personnes de la noyade
ce que je veux dire par là c'est qu'il
ya beaucoup d'indicateurs qui montrent
que ça va pas et que les visiteurs
encourent des risques énormes sauf que
les gérants du parc s'en bat les steaks
à 1000 %
résultat trois morts dans cette [ __ ]
de piscine à vagues dans cette partie
waterworld on pouvait aussi trouver une
attraction qui s'appelle the times of
swing franchement pour le coup ça a
l'air archicool comme son nom l'indiqué
budget du rebord et à l'arrivée tu fais
un petit salto pour les plus courageux
ou un seau normal pour le moins
courageux mois et atterri dans l'eau
c'est un peu rigolo à faire c'est
toujours cool sauf que dans le quotidien
est rarement une liane qui traîne pour
te permettre de faire ça là franchement
c'est l'occasion d'essayer de qui fait
un peu un mort
c'est bon en fait c'est le différentiel
de température entre l'eau de toutes les
attractions du parc lots de cette
attraction là ce qui fait que
régulièrement les gens qui atterrissait
dans le bassin il a été victime
d'hydrocution autrement appelée choc
thermique
en gros le différentiel de température
entre leur corps et l'eau faisait qui
s'évanouissaient en fait même les trucs
les plus simples étaient mal pensé y
avait par exemple un endroit pour faire
un saut de 5 ou 7 mètres dans l'eau sauf
que le bassin dans lequel les gens
atterrissait était aussi un bassin pour
nager et donc souvent il y avait des
collisions entre les gens qui sautaient
et les gens qui nageait en bas et qu'ils
savaient pas que c'était un patient
destiné aussi au saut et c'est trop con
si les blessures qui pourraient être
largement évité je veux dire le parc est
tellement énorme tu peux totalement dire
bah voilà les bassins pour se baigner
juste nager c'est là là et là et ce
bassin est dédié lui que au sommet à
l'époque on est au tout début des parcs
d'attraction de cette envergure du moins
et donc tout ça n'est pas encore mis en
place quoi je ne sais pas parler de
kayak ça s'arrête jamais vu l'expérience
kayak en français c'est une attraction
qui est archi comble sur le papier tu
prends un kayak tu vas dans l'eau et il
ya des eaux rapides créé
artificiellement grâce à des hélices qui
sont sous l'eau amor amor en 1982 un
homme de 27 ans est tombé de son kayak
dans les eaux rapides et en voulant
remonter dans son kayak
il a touché un câble électrique qui
alimentait les fameuses ellis
responsable des eaux rapides
il est mort sur le coup électrocutées et
bien évidemment le parc à rejeter toutes
les accusations en disant il est mort
électrocuté mais ya pas de traces de
brûlures sur son corps c'est qu'il est
mort d'autres choses et que donc on
n'est pas responsable
bref y avait aussi pas mal d'attractions
aquatique plus classiques comme des
toboggans en tout genre genre des trucs
que tu descends un plat vente avec de
légères boss
waouh c'est quoi cette bosse et tout ça
nous amène à l'attraction aquatique la
plus célèbre tristement de ce parc
le cadeau de bolt mais regardez-moi la
gueule de ce toboggan bordel faut pas
être un génie et en physique 1 pour
comprendre que ça va très mal se passer
à l'intérieur de ce toboggan fait savoir
qu'il ya tellement de gens qui restés
coincés qu'ils ont mis haineux trappe
pour que des maîtres nageurs puissent
venir aider les gens coincés pour les
décoincer alors c'est triste mais la
plupart de ceux qui sortaient de ce
tonneau d'or avec les pétés ou saignée
de quelques parts sur le visage et
petite précision l'eau dans laquelle tu
atterris c'est à la sortie de ce
toboggan
c'était la même que l'eau de la traction
tarzan tu avais résister aux chocs
physiques très bien mais allez tu
résister aux chocs thermiques ne
sam couronner le tout il était possible
dans ce parc d'acheter de l'alcool
beaucoup d'alcool et si on donnait de
l'alcool aux gens avant d'aller nager
dans notre incroyable piscine à vagues
bon vous l'aurez compris avec des
énormes faille de sécurité dans
énormément d'attraction du parc ce qui a
entraîné un nombre de blessures énorme
et malheureusement six morts à tel point
d'ailleurs que les gérants du parc ont
payé pour qui est tout le temps des
ambulances sur place
en cas de problème les urgences du coin
d'ailleurs dit plus tard qu'ils leur
arrivaient dans les week-end chargé de
recevoir jusqu'à 20 personnes par jour
alors comment on en est arrivé là c'est
la question que je me pose et je me suis
dit mais comment c'est possible comment
la police le tribunal où quand comment
d'aider des associations chepan ne sont
pas venus pour dire mais les gars vous
êtes en roue libre
vous êtes en grande roue libre je suis
fier déjà il faut savoir que la plupart
des attractions du parc comme pour le
verdict n'avait malheureusement pas été
design et par des ingénieurs pourquoi
pas déjà puisque c'était pas obligatoire
et ensuite pour économiser des sous ça
coûte cher un ingénieur en parlant du
staff la plupart des gens qui bossent et
là bas c'était en fait des jeunes qui
faisaient un job d'été qui n'était
clairement pas qualifié pour gérer mille
[ __ ] de personnes dans une piscine à
vagues ou des collisions entre un mec
qui saute de 7 mètres sur un mec qui
nagent sa meilleure brasse il était
clairement pas formés pour assumer un
nombre de visiteurs aussi énorme et pour
assurer la sécurité des visiteurs pour
des attractions si dangereuse et aussi
mal foutu alors rassurez-vous actionne
parc a fermé en 1996 et c'est pas du
tout liés au procès engendrés par les
morts et les blessures qui a eu dans
toute leur attraction c'est juste que le
groupe qui détenait le parc a fait
faillite tout simplement le pas qui va
alors être acheté par plusieurs
compagnies qui vont tout faire faillite
jusqu'à être achetés en 2010 par le
propriétaire originel du parc eugène
mule ville qui va décéder deux ans après
en 2012 donc le parc va se retrouver
entre les mains de son fils et son fils
valeureux nommé à je voulais pas dit
mais entre temps l'une des compagnies
qui avait racheté le parc la baie
renommer en mountain creek parce que les
gens avaient beaucoup entendu parler de
action par comme un parc étant
extrêmement dangereux que ça nuisait
donc au business on va jouer sur la
nostalgie c'est bon pour les affaires
entre temps dans les groupes qui avait
racheté le parquet a eu pas mal de
rénovation et de modifications qui ont
été faites il est devenu beaucoup moins
dangereux mais le fils du propriétaire
et en tout compris il décide quand même
de faire une nouvelle attraction unique
en son genre avec les loopings
vous avez un problème dans cette famille
voilà c'est l'incroyable
l'histoire deux actions parc je trouve
ça fou dans les années 80 cette course à
la consommation en fait tout allait
hyper vite tout le monde voulait
construire un peu son empire et la
législation elle suivait pas et c'est
trop triste parce qu'il ya eu six
personnes qui sont décédées dans ce
[ __ ] de parc et il ya eu des tas
d'état des tas de gens qui ont eu des
blessures de malades
je trouve ça hyper flippant heureusement
on est en 2020 ça a beaucoup changé les
régulations autour de tout ça je sais
qu'en france je crois que les lois a
vis-à-vis des fêtes foraines et des
parcs d'attractions elle rigole vraiment
pas mais chaque pays a ses propres lois
et du coup je savais pas que aux us y
avait des zones là comme au new jersey
où il s'en bat les couilles quoi c'est
ouf voilà fallait que je raconte tout ça
et j'ai trouvé ça incroyablement dingue
c'est ça vous a fait qui fait peut-être
qu'on se refera d'autres trucs comme ça
pas forcément sur les attractions c'est
un peu baba mais dès qu'il tomberait sur
des histoires un peu whaou que je ne
soupçonnais pas d'exister ben pourquoi
pas en parlant vidéo avec vous ça me
fait kiffer nous faire découvrir ce que
j'ai découvert bref je vous embrasse
bien fort
prenez soin de vous pour défendre vos
proches et puis ac
[Musique]